what is the most beautiful place you
have ever been and when you were there
did you take a picture of it here's a
place that tops that list from me this
is mesa arch in Canyonlands National
Park in Utah at sunrise it's the
traditional homeland of the Pueblo ute
Paiute and Navajo people and when you
are there it is absolutely stunning
the sunrise illuminates the bottom of
the arch orange and then behind it you
see these buttes and clouds and cliffs
but what you might not see from my photo
here is the 30 people behind me who are
also taking photos and these are just
the committed people the sunrise people
right so when you think about that there
must be hundreds if not thousands of
photos of mesa arch taken every week
I've been sharing my photography on
Instagram for years and it started to
become really interesting and funny even
just how many similar photos of the same
places I started to see online and I was
participating in it so this made me
wonder why are we taking photos in the
first place sometimes I visit a popular
landmark this one is Horseshoe Bend in
Arizona and I see all the people with
their phones and cameras out who snap a
photo just to turn and get back in the
car or walk back to the trailhead and
sometimes it seems like we are missing
the point of you know going to this
place to experience it for ourselves or
to see it with our own eyes when I'm
behind the camera I notice the smallest
details the layers of light in the
mountains as the light fades at the end
of the day the shapes that nature so
expertly makes abstract and yet
completely perfect I could go on and on
here musing about the intricacies of
this planet and the way that it makes me
feel photographing the beauty and
complexity of this world for me is like
making a portrait of someone that I love
and when I make a photograph I have to
think about what I wanted to say I have
to ask myself what I want it to feel
like when you're communicating through
an image every creative choice matters
sometimes I plan to share my images and
other times I take them just for myself
I currently host a video series on the
future of the outdoors and for one of
the episodes we wanted to explore the
relationship between photography and
outdoor spaces I learned about the
research of Kristin deal and her
colleagues at USC who studied photo
takings effect on enjoyment levels they
found that when we were behind the
camera and we're the ones taking a
picture we enjoy our experiences more
not less but it wasn't true all the time
if the person took the photo solely with
the intention of sharing it there was no
increase in enjoyment because they
didn't do it for themselves so this
points to an important distinction
Photography can enhance your experience
if it's done intentionally the intention
piece is what matters
as a photographer I've really had to
check myself on this when does it help
me to have my camera out and when do I
just need to put it away on a trip to
Alaska I had the opportunity to
photograph Alaskan brown bears I was on
a boat with four other photographers and
we were all having our minds blown at
the same time in such close proximity to
these animals and it's an emotional
experience being eye-to-eye with these
bears gave me a feeling of connection
that transcends words and having my
camera with me in this case enhanced
that we were all creating independently
but also all completely in the moment
both with nature and with each other I
so clearly remember capturing the water
droplets and the motion as the bear swam
and the cute Cubs following their
mothers that group and I will have that
experience together and these images to
look back on time and time again and
photography is what enabled us to share
this in the first place other times I
choose to leave the camera behind and I
think that choice ultimately improves
both my experience and my work I
recently flew to the South Pacific
island of Tonga to swim with humpback
whales I noticed myself feeling pressure
and
certain obligation to take the camera
with me when sometimes I just wanted the
pure experience itself and the
experience is seriously amazing you're
talking about being in the water with a
curious baby animal the size of a
station wagon well you are surrounded by
particles that float around you like
glitter and the mom swims gracefully
below you
there were times obviously when I did
take my camera with me and those were
really amazing to capture as well but
the setup is pretty big it's like this
big box this is what it looks like and
so this is between me and the whales and
at times that feels like a block between
you and reality is there a difference
when it's just your phone last year I
went to Uluru in Central Australia which
is this massive rock that towers over
the desert this is sacred land to on on
you who are the Aboriginal people from
this area and the traditional owners of
the land there are particular spots in
uluru that you cannot photograph
professionally because they are
culturally sensitive equivalent to
secret scripture so on on you so because
of this most of my photographs are from
either far away like this one or from
specific angles in the park you could
say that some of the most interesting
and beautiful visuals in Oulu are
located in these sensitive areas but the
requests not to photograph them is an
explicit and direct invitation to learn
more about the land its importance and
its people isn't that what we should be
doing anyway
so my visit to aru quickly became not
about me but about connecting with the
place ironically and unsurprisingly I
have found that presence and connection
also happens to make for more compelling
images we can probably all point to
social media as being a good place to
share the images from our travels and
from our lives we not only share pieces
of the world that we have seen but also
parts of our day-to-day experiences and
if we're applying intentionality to the
photos we take then hopefully we're
sharing intentionally - for me allowing
people to see pieces of my story and my
perspective online has reminded me that
I'm not alone it's helped me build
support and community
to do the same for others let me be
clear I am NOT trying to discourage you
from taking photos even if thousands of
people have been to whatever exact
location and taken whatever exact photo
I encourage you to get out and create to
the world needs every voice and
perspective and yours is included but
what I'm trying to show you is that the
phone or camera doesn't have to stay out
all the time what I'm trying to
encourage you to do is to put it away
just for a moment a moment for you so
let's go back to Mesa arch the way that
the rock glows Orange and the lovely
layers of blue in the background what if
the next time you are somewhere amazing
you couldn't bring your camera or phone
what if you are not allowed to take any
pictures at all would it feel like a
limitation or would it feel like a
relief so what can we do well the next
time you feel the impulse to take out
your camera or phone or in my case once
you realize you have already pulled it
out first stop pause take a deep breath
look around what do you notice
are you experiencing this moment with
someone else remember that this moment
only comes once photography can be part
of a beautiful experience just don't let
it be a block between you and reality be
intentional and don't lose a beautiful
irreplaceable memory because you were
too focused on getting the shot thank
you
[Applause]